okay
right good afternoon everyone
chancellors
[Music]
uh thank you for uh coming to the
meeting uh
or certainly meeting on at two o'clock
i appreciate everybody
you know changing the time because of
me mostly because i couldn't get it at
10.
so i appreciate everybody being able to
come along and lose their schedules a
bit thank you very much
and welcome to all the people on youtube
who are not about streaming us at this
time
um
we'll start off with apologies for
you chad abstinence we're going to
receive from mr evan harper
councillor langford
councillor potter hunkin and council
watson
the country leather and substitute
council watson
thank
[Music]
[Music]
there's page three to start with
page four
page five
page five picture hangs
let's see the second paragraph up to the
bottom just should be more
[Music]
seven
[Music]
[Music]
and seconded all those in favor
anyone against those abstentions
okay
moving on
to the action desk
um i believe this is this has been
updated
i believe everybody's had an
email of the updates there
is everybody happy
with those um
things that comes on there is anybody
already
[Music]
any more questions on the action list
all right thank you for that
all right moving on again then to
public contributions
we have them
um
declarations of interest i think
everybody is aware of the situation
there
whereas it matters brought forward with
the division of the chair i have no
do you have anything to do i think sure
no okay
okay
um
there's no part two sorry there's no
part two
um items
so we move on to the qpr
job
his kind of role of doing the uh
the few slides on the performance um for
the qbr
this these slides are looking back this
is the whole year this is picture four
um so we'll just have a flip through
some of the some of the highlights
you've probably seen uh some of this
throughout the year um
but it's just nice to have a little
update
so
some of the highlights under the theme
of the local economy
um we've got the community
real fund um in place
which helps kickstart the local economy
new borough centre that provided a good
visitor boost for
numbers and or
some new jobs
lots of work on discretionary grants
to help local businesses
the council has transferred a hundred
thousand pounds to the welcome back
funding to town councils
um
there are some bookable meeting rooms at
the new refurbished thorough center
we've had over a hundred businesses over
a thousand businesses signed up
to the northern uh devon d scbar app
we were the highest
funded district nationally to the
community renewal fund
and the businesses and community
organizations
were asked to
register for their devon elevation fund
we got money um
towards helping us uh progress the
northern level futures and members um
supported some additional funding for
that alongside north dakota council
around petrol
the council continued to work with the
help part of the southwest lab and north
durham council
to explore supply chain opportunities
within the floating offshore wind
developments
supporting our local businesses 99.8
of our invoices are paid on time
or within terms should i say
local earnings have increased by 10.4
in 2021
and unemployment fell
to 2.8 and i'll just show you that a
little bit more now
quite an interesting slide this one
you'll see that kind of last year shows
how torrent was really
impacted um
for unemployment uh at 4.4 and now um
kind of the end of the
previous financial year we're now back
kind of
on par as we were before it all kicked
off so it's a an interesting little stat
to see that little spike
so move on to communities housing
housing
got a few more um
highlights here
we got a 25 thousand pound grand from
the lga to help us with our strategic
housing delivery plan
um the council again um
max fund that so we've got
some money that we can actually go back
um this project
and there will be a report going to full
council in july
the council safeguarding policy has been
updated and adopted by field council
the affordable housing supplementary
planning documents been completed and
put out for public consultation
full programme of events provided by
rangers at northern barrows for the
school summer holidays
and bystander domestic abuse training
works been undertaken to ensure that a
newly created independent measure
organization active torridge
was able to commence operating on the
first of april
joint planning policy committee in
january agreed to take the affordable
housing spd through to final adoption
and following review of public
consultation
the dog and drinking control provisions
a new pspl was adopted
a few little kind of negatives for this
one
[Music]
during the year for the committee
significant increase in numbers of
households living in temperate
accommodation and work has been
undertaken to try to address that
um
and again kind of statistically wise the
price of properties in the district
increased by 18
in 2021 which further you know mentally
that the housing prices
we've got uh communities health and
housing
so
um that's kind of a stat and a graph to
show you the
housing pressures
uh so torridge um this is a number of
temporary accommodations per one
thousand per thousand episodes
so this is our family group
and we are kind of the third highest in
that and we are now above the english
district average which
we haven't seen before
so you can see that there has been a
priority now for us and there's been a
lot of work with john and our teamster
to look into it
theme our environment of future
carbon environment and bio diversity
plan adopted by phil caxil
westwood hill beach been awarded the
blue [ __ ] status 19th year in a row
we had a high take-up in the garden west
um optional garden waste service
which was good for the income as well as
for the recycling
weekly waste and recycling mulchers
hopes again to further visual recycling
levels
the climate and sustainability officer
issued our carbon footprint figures
cnr
committee voted to endorse north durham
biosphere's national
nature resourcing plan and declaration
it sets out the vision for nature in the
area
we disposed of bridge buildings which is
a really inefficient building
and
came to a set and approved active
porridge
which will guide how the new leisure
company be operated and managed in 2022
grains maintenance came back in-house as
well
um and the people in place project part
of the local plan review was software
for the media and social media
so again lots going on
along there
this is um
just a graph to show our recycling mates
um
interestingly there you see there's a
little blip there we've gone down from
from last year
um
last year
the
we we got to the trend um
across seven we
actually went up from the previous year
when others went down now we're seeing
that middle decline and that's where
things seem to be uh evening out a bit
since the pandemic that's something that
just keep an eye out
we've got uh thing four here this is a
load of stats and now that we're using
in our annual reports just being drafted
so there's lots of things going on
two and a half million wasted recycling
collections
um
lots of fois
visitors to a website
millions paid out
so yeah there's just just a few stats
there just to show you you know there is
lots and lots going on
and i say that will be in the
report
this graph here shows kind of how we're
working on the channel shift
and how things kind of progressed and
how kind of colby's kick-started
this even more
lots more visits to the
website it looks here that on on there
that has slightly gone down but that's
because of the new government
way of
monitoring it you have to accept
cookies before you can count it so if
you don't accept or you refuse the
acceptance it's not counting so we're
we're expecting to see that that will
either increase or or level out next uh
next year once we've got more of a
baseline
but it does show a lot of kind of
um demand being met kind of um digitally
going forward
uh this one we're just showing you a
little example of the the planning um
[Music]
shift um showing you
one of the percentages and
numbers that have been received
electronically
and um
kind of
average phone calls and things like that
so it's just another
um
and it shows that the visitors to the
reception has decreased as well but it's
showing that a lot now are being done
online which is a much more um efficient
way of dealing with it
so that's kind of just a brief preview
of the stats um
that over the last uh
12 months if anybody's got any questions
before i pass over to david to go
through the finances
did you say the number of phone calls is
increased
now the
phone calls
so that would be the
the phone calls and the mobiles are they
really increased obviously during the
pandemic and now they
they started to go
since then it's been an impression that
it takes longer the waiting times are
longer now we've thrown up
like this sort of
used to be a viewing system
it's it's the same it's the same system
as it has been over the years
quite a long time sometimes it causes
staff problems
not aware that there's been any
complaints about people having to wait
any length of time and a lot of teams
have got direct dial numbers as well i
don't know if steve wants to add
anything
yeah
we haven't had any uh particular
complaints um obviously is it the
facility to leave messages as well
which is something that's been happening
particularly with some of the
new schemes
of course
the green line is
a short like
john
said cause unsearched
particular problem yeah
i think it's true as well there's more
options
isn't it it's nine isn't it what's six
before
that's nine
and i mean if you want to you can
which i've done in the past if you want
to
talk to the customer services
you haven't got to listen to all nine
you just push nine and it gets you right
through to
whatever department you want you just
push that number
and it goes right through them so you
can you have to listen to all nine
options have you no that's quite right
and yeah
there are various different ways of
contacting us as you said so that that
is purely if you dial the switchboard
number yes but a lot of teams have got
direct dial numbers and
team you know like that as well
okay
any other questions there
that's just an idea
just a good idea to put the figure 9
make members aware
that they haven't got their details
they just press nine it used to be six
first obviously it's changed
yeah
yes okay so there's nine options now
they've put a few more options on there
then
and nine is the last one if you can't if
the better line options aren't any
any good to you
and then you go through to the operator
right or the customer services
operator
[Music]
[Music]
imagine the word
the draft surplus that is financially at
72 21 22 is 172
000 pounds
and that's actually an increase of
thousand pounds from what was reported
to members in quarter through
uh i think it's important because i seem
to be giving this messages to um
counselors at the moment i'm giving
messages of
exceptional financial strain upon the
council in terms of his bridges going
forward
from
the biggest surplus
and possibly in the council's history
since i've been in post tourist district
council
on the
second page of your report
you have some of the key
adverse viruses and the key favorable
variances
and i'll just very briefly reiterate
what they are
and finally
we've had two years that have been
exceptional in terms of planning
actually more than doubled the actual
budget so the normal year would have
been around 550 600 000
in the last two financial years we've
exceeded that massively we've gone 1.1
million and nearly 1.3 million last year
2020
nearly 670 000 pounds surplus
on our planet income
the other big factor as to why we could
surplus
as um
john alluded to in his presentation
he uh showed all the
extra work the council put in just
dispute business support grants track
and trace payments etc now we've
received funding for the government for
that in excess of the money we've
actually incurred in expenditure
and that various transit that's almost
618 directly call with related business
grants and over grants of 169 000 so
we've got the best part six and seven
thousand thousand grants which to a
large degree
that's been absorbed by the council's
workforce there's been some agents that
certainly been some overtime
said they've been some um stresses and
straight but it's largely absorbed by
the council
um one of our other biggest countries
actually
is negative it's our staffing vacancies
we set a target of staff payments in 300
000. we overachieved that by 218
thousand which meant over half a million
pounds of staffing savings just arising
purely from vacant so when you think
that
in excess of the third of our workforce
is front line in terms of refuge street
cleansing et cetera and when they're
when we have vacancies today we've back
filled up with agencies pretty much
straight away that's your schedule that
shows the recruitment crisis that we
face as a council
we obviously made extra money on car
park with the access vehicle access to
the northern boroughs one because it was
a good year two because we did actually
increase the charges slightly free
because dedication and difficulties
people have gone abroad
a new um
underspend is with torres district
councils members of what's called the
devon business rate call where we any of
our surplus business rate income goes
into a bill and gets redistributed back
out and that saves us something over 50
percent of our surplus to central
government
we only know those figures
at the end of the year when the last
person submits their return to the major
surface of 109 000 pounds on that
so in the report
it looks dirty to the future and defers
the decision to community and resources
so we've got an additional surplus of
circus six hundred thousand they've been
previously reported so what we're going
to do with that 600 000
well at the moment it's a watching brief
in our medium term financial strategy
we've assumed a 2
pay award
i think tomorrow i'm on a employer's
call where i'll get some insights to
what the employers will be offering to
the unions the unions can
claim
or request is in excess of 10
which obviously is the financial
strategy financial challenge to the
council
so at the moment i believe the offer
from the employers will be an excessive
function but i'll find out more tomorrow
so i want to hold fire on what we're
going to do with the surplus until we
have more detail on that and work
through the potential consequences of
any offer that is made
um we're also actually spending the
minimum living wage lifted by inflation
which means it'll come very very close
to our bottom grade
and within
two years if your cameras aren't going
up about inflation that'll really
fundamentally undermine our grading
structure of the council i'm going to
have to look at our radio ship
and that'll come with additional costs
and as everybody's aware supply related
issues that everybody's facing in the
world and particularly in construction
price inflation and that will impact on
the council such as the new
environmental center
so in some ways what the report says is
wow what a surplus with that it's six
hundred thousand better than last time
but put the champagne on ice because um
they're dark times ahead
and it's really only asking for members
to note the contents of the report and
i'll follow the report we'll go to see
now where we've got more information
particularly about the employer's pay
offer to the unions because that's on
the basis of what i'll say our budget
against
i'm happy to take any questions at this
point
any questions
well
does the college
comment that the uh the homeless
situation is going to get worse worse is
the cost
[Music]
that's one of the reasons i've
previously been reporting to members of
the budget working group while we're
here to try and
put this
budget on a more sustainable basis
because it's one of the cost prices it's
not just uh
i think i've said a various meetings and
i'll repeat
going forward the biggest pressure on
the council is increased expenditure
inflation
leisure
and the homelessness crisis we're not
immune to the homosexuals who have a
responsibility for the
financial pain for almost this crisis
any other questions
that's been submitted
unfortunately
mr harper isn't here but um
you can see the answers there is there
any
other
um
comments to make on the first
question there
remember
move on to the second question then by
mister danger
mr jack that's it you've got anymore
you're happy with that
okay
anybody have snapper yes move on to the
throat well
you again mr dickman
probably should have expanded the
question a bit more if it was more the
next steps for
foreign
[Music]
um
that's really without thinking
not the reports yourself but what comes
next for us right
for sure
um
next up the next questions are on the
highlights
um
theme three capture homes
um
yeah it doesn't seem a brilliant
response to me to our
survey
too 284
completed surveys
out of the whole of the tourist
population
i believe still yes
so
yeah i mean this is trouble with surveys
sometimes
you know people aren't
from this time round we're supposed to
be committed to
greater transparency and involvement to
the public so we need to
it has been publicized probably more
than we did when we were doing the last
local planners you can't force people to
respond
what we now progress in with
is looking at how we
consult with towns and parish councils
that's another avenue that goes out that
way
members of those towns and parish
councils can encourage uh their
residents and constituents to to engage
so that's one of the next
we're looking to set some dates up in
the diaries for those meetings uh
shortly
yeah obviously you've got to do it for
specific avenues but let us wonder
whether the survey is going to be
in future better designs and more
attractive more appealing maybe
i think it's someone you need to look at
anyway i don't surveys
don't always produce a good response but
we still need to try and increase the
response
well
yeah i mean with the surveys i mean
um
i think the trouble with surveys is you
only get comments from people you want
to make complaints or something like
that
whereas
the people who are
quite uh happy with everything
so you've never gotta
well i personally put positive comments
on it yeah yeah i mean there is probably
lots of colors on that
but you know what i mean it's um
it's very difficult for me to
to know what people are saying if you're
not sick
[Music]
[Music]
is this consultation on government
i thought it was because i i've had
some residents again or not some one or
two residents email them and i pointed
them in this direction
because they were questioning the
current
local development plan
and i said well we've just started
beginning of this year
reviewing the normal plan
which is quite a long process anyway
but any comments you want to make
towards future operations make them to
that
point
[Music]
yes
so
are you happy with that
yes i think both that question and the
next question i think it just really is
the pressure that the council is facing
on the staff side
from trying to train up which is
brilliant but obviously it takes the
existing team to
to do that so it takes time away so it's
just checking there's nothing
you know training
and the same with the birth
about
um
that's the next one's from you as well
you're happy with that yes yes
uh mr harper's the next one but does
anybody want to
comment on his
question there or the answer
is okay
the next one's from mr harper as well
local economy
is everybody
happy with that answer
you can't ask mr paul
that's okay then move it on
there is quite a few of these this is
good actually
um
page 10 and local comment again thanks
for hangs that's right yes
that's right
that's okay isn't it good right okay mr
harper is the next one page 11.
um
everybody happy with that
good
moving on this is for you again
yeah what work
question seems a bit disappointing i
just hope you know
some council's obviously invested time
and money in the work
it's not my area but i was just
interested right
but um
hopefully the you know the whole basis
of the project the rationale is is
correct that there's
you know
for such a hug
yes
right
uh page 12 local comedy again that's
your language she's not here does
everybody
understand the question they answer them
anyone
want to make any comments there
okay thank you
um
question for cancer langford
our environment our future page 19
and
everyone happy
maybe you understand the question of the
answer
okay
for that
this is one for you again mr uh
counselor aims
page 21
i've lost the page
oh some of the back
right sorry apologies
page fourteen
cancer language
page sixteen council nine first
so um everybody happy there
[Music]
so there we go
page 19 yes page 19
kentucky
if this was just there
[Music]
everybody happy with that question
answered
any comments
[Music]
thank you
the page 21
yeah thank you so um
some work to be done on the way to
figures and reported
janet williams has referred to here
thank
[Music]
right so that's been all
explained there
[Music]
gonna ask yes i don't know if that's
cancelled
what happens to all the uh electrical
equipment
is that shipped
actually
[Music]
that's something we can ask a
delicious haste about
and who
do that where
toxins
[Music]
yeah that's what i understand as well
but we'll get we're going to report that
on the action list all right
next one is from mr denge again
are you happy
thank you yes um i was getting excited
about the harboring but obviously yes
okay
next one is from mr harper
simply
understand the answer question answer
here
is everybody happy
right
um mr dengue again
complaints questions
okay next next one's you again
yeah okay i think they take it together
okay
uh life report again
everybody understand the question the
answer hopefully happened with that
question from mr harper
[Music]
again everybody clear on that question
and that's what's for you mr tanker
thank you
i guess it's just a question of how
much that
housing element gets
right the less
issue
so what's this new measure it's referred
to in a question of mister
mr bender
mentioned
let's
remind us what that was
of course
that's uh
this is something you can find actually
in
any email people around yeah
[Music]
affordable housing delivered on sites
that qualify for affordable housing and
it says moon measure to be better
for 2021
right so that's right
now
but we'll check on that in the action
just anyway just
right everybody happy with the tbr any
other questions
answered
someone
[Music]
you can always input on a local plan and
put our thoughts there as well
can't we
okay
coach remember thank you
on the affordable 30 that is a target
but of course developers and that and
applicants applications
it's put viability appraisals
away
lots of other
items come out of the cost of
development sites
education highways
medical coming in a lot more negative
asking for money
so it all whittles away
the applicant puts in the viability
appraisal we get it assessed
uh
to the cost of the uh
we get it assessed
and normally it seems to fall in line
with what the applicants are put in
there is we are going to have um
um
somebody come and speak to us the plans
committee i think probably all
councilman
on section one or six and identity
appraisal but i mean it is a problem
that
is difficult to overcome currently
yes you know they probably didn't say we
have before this you can only afford 15
or 10.
here are the figures to show why
um
the only thing we are doing we we're now
starting
to put claws into reducing these
viability equations because the way the
housing market has moved in pricing over
the past few months
it could well be like two years down the
line when some of these properties are
built and up for sale they could be
worth a lot more than what was in the
original viability appraisal so
there'll be a clawback system hopefully
but it will certainly be a review of
that
and it would make a lot more concern
than them as i said when they put the
viability present forward
they wouldn't either took any more money
yeah like i say
we uh
go on about this all
morning i think it's something that we
should be
sort of
putting our views through to the local
plan
and i think it's a good idea that we
have
people coming along and talking about
bundle sixes and things like that
and you know perhaps we should be
engaging with developers more perhaps i
don't know but um you know
yes i think we will leave this until
such times that we can have a
good debate about it
okay
thank you
um moving forward then
if they have any questions
[Music]
um
really for
steve i think is the qbr on each time we
publish it as well as going out to all
councillors now
is it also in the public domain
and are the are the questions and
answers which provide the granularity to
the qpr especially in the majority from
r2 esteemed independent members um
do they are they also in the public
domain yes
they are this part of otherwise it
wouldn't be in this part of the beating
yeah yeah so they published as an
addendum to the agenda on the website on
whatcap so there are available to
anybody who still wishes to
look and review them okay
all right any other questions
right
about the agenda again
and a report to receive the report of
the chair
i think this is just for noting
um
any questions i suppose
assuming that you've already
catch your name
yeah
additional work carried out social
values
did you just say what's pitch
page 60
social media's tasked and finished yes
we have a meeting
and we were addressed by the lady from
exeter
council
it says here we're waiting that's we're
waiting for the national legislation
well
we have any idea when that might be
ready because seriously we need to sort
of get on with looking at
insight procurement etc
john has some clear updates and other
legislations going through the
parliamentary process not quite sure
where exactly it is it's um it's in the
second meeting of the house of lords at
the moment
um
i was going to suggest that we add this
to the forward plan for your next item
anyway social media
the idea would be for the um
finish group to
meet
one or two times prior to the
legislation coming out
but the idea wasn't to finalize anything
because at the moment it's looking like
the legislation
will be mandatory
so we don't want to set something up
ourselves then have to change it because
of those legislation but we can be in a
position that would have something
kind of ready to
okay thank you john
so anybody anything else in the report
all right then
um
part two so
uh well the consideration of the forward
plan then
so we've got to put that on the forward
plan yeah
before the chair had to go off um for
the family fumble um we ran through a
few items that we knew were coming up
okay so i thought if i run through them
um where we provisionally put them on
and if committees are happy we can leave
them on if there's anything they want to
move around they can if there's anything
they want to add that they can
um so we had a discussion with the chair
before we went
we went away
so for
the next meeting we've got qbl one on
the agenda um
we should have by then or we will have
by then the first release of the census
results
so
the recommendation was to bring a report
to
to this committee um with the census
results for charge um the uh they won't
be all the results are gonna uh um
announce them um kind of periodically
but the ones that are announced we can
bring to you guys so you'll see what um
the census results are saying
for the torridge area so the suggestion
for for your 26th
july meeting was to have the census
returns to it so
whether
the committee's banked about that um
um moving on to september
um
i'm working on a a draft digital by
default strategy
um the last one was i believe four years
ago and it came to this committee
before it goes to cnr for adoption so um
the suggestion again was to bring it to
this committee for them to have a look
at
the draft digital by default strategy
[Music]
it was also looking at maybe trying to
get an update from janet on the housing
strategy because i know that was
something from last year
um and
the the other two items uh of uh
suggestions were
an update on that leisure service
provision and the grants maintenance
just to see how that's been ticking long
after
um what would be what um
six months i suppose
of operation
so those are
a few more things um for the agenda if
anybody's got any thoughts on that
i'm just
i mean it's moved on gdpr and cyber
security
there will be a separate cyber
policy developed alongside that but that
will be referenced in the
rap
your phone great thanks
uh john the
active torridge are under omit to
do a review in september october time
um especially linked to a vibrant
will that come
via is that coming by this committee or
plan coming download to full council as
was with the requirement
and incorporated the position at six
months so there's no real need for it to
come to internal as it's going to all
end as a tall council
[Music]
the other kind of addition we were
thinking for the december meeting was
the social value update i'm anticipating
one or two meetings before that at the
task and finish group
um but what we're hop be able to provide
is a an update to the committee of how
we've got on but also um
being a position to see how far their
legislation goes
so um it was uh looking at december for
that but obviously if if the legislation
comes through quicker or the tasks and
finish groups finish quickly we can
vacuum back the move it's
[Music]
[Music]
does anybody want to add anything to
them
okay well there you go that's the
thank you
to be the end
of the meeting